ces photos ont agité la sphère du web
toute la journée
elle montre un 4/4 à côté d'une scène
des français là où ces produits
l'humoriste dieudonné hier soir à neuvy
sautour petite commune de l'yonne
les faits se sont déroulés sur ce champ
privé vers 18 heures des techniciens
préparent la scène pour dieudonné un
voisin arrive alors à bord de son
véhicule pour demander ce qu'il se passe
le ton monte et l'individu pour des
raisons encore inconnues fausses sur
l'estrade
quatre personnes sont légèrement
blessées et l'une d'elles est mordu par
le conducteur en essayant de maîtriser
âgé d'une cinquantaine d'années
l'agresseur est médecin dans la commune
coup de folie peur d'être dérangés par
le spectacle placé depuis en garde à vue
il est toujours entendu par la
gendarmerie
une enquête a été ouverte sur place
difficile de vérifier les informations
les seuls témoins directs que nous avons
pu rencontrer sur les organisateurs du
spectacle
l'un d'entre eux est aussi propriétaire
du terrain et travaille régulièrement
pour dieudonné
le maire lui n'a pas souhaité répondre à
nos questions était-il au courant de la
tenue du spectacle
pourrait-il prendre un arrêté pour
l'interdire quant à la préfecture elle a
tout de suite démenti toute tentative de
meurtre sur la personne de dieudonné
mais depuis ne communique plus sur le
sujet